let's suppose we're gonna do a workshop
right here today building a story world
sure how would we begin it so we're
talking about story world's we need to
separate stories from story worlds so
story worlds are places and stories are
things that happen in those places and
so a lot of what I found a lot of people
they they don't understand what a story
world is you know some people say well
my my story world is my you know
characters coming-of-age sexuality or
whatever that's not a story world that's
some like a character arc a story world
literally is a geographical place it's
it's it's it you know we know we
understand the story of Lord of the
Rings and Frodo and the ring and the
journey destroy the ring but the the
story world is middle-earth sonio story
is is in the matrix is about his
adventure with with Morpheus and taking
down the matrix and against the machines
the agent Smith and all that stuff but
the story world the matrix is a
futuristic earth that's been taken over
by machines and they use people as
batteries in the VR environment so story
wells are places and that's what you
have to understand but it's not just any
place it's any place that is interesting
has to be interesting by itself and so
most people when they when they develop
content they develop scripts or their TV
for our features or books the most
interesting things they have are their
characters and their plots and then they
relegate story role to setting as your
setting is just simply where my story
takes place but just because you have a
setting doesn't necessarily mean you
have a story world a story world is a
setting that has independent interest so
it's interest that's independent of any
character independent of any story so my
rule of thumb is can you take your main
character your protagonists your hero
can you take them out of the story world
and have your story world still be
interesting right can you take the story
out of the story world and still have it
be interesting so I can right now take
Luke Skywalker
out of Star Wars and the Star Wars
galaxy still interesting I can take
Frodo out of middle-earth middle-earth
middle-earth is still interesting I can
take bay
acts out of big hero six and San
fransokyo still interesting right but
can you take rocky out of Rocky it's a
different calculation right because you
think well they're doing that with creed
what creed still has rocky but I mean
it's it's if we take rocky out of Rocky
then we have Philadelphia which is the
setting but there's nothing
independently interesting about
Philadelphia no offense to Philadelphia
right so but but the interest of rocky
comes through rocky and Creed and the
characters but the place itself isn't
interesting you look at something like
Gotham with Batman you can take Batman
on the Gotham and you can have a whole
TV show about it right because the place
in and of itself is super interesting
and when you have an interesting setting
that creates your story world you now
you now have stored potential and so you
will never any creator any any writer
any director any filmmaker they will
never truly understand the revenue
potential of their brand or their IP
unless they actually understand their
story world story worlds create story
potential story potential creates
revenue potential and and so and then
revenue potential makes buyers happy
they make you know the investors happy
they keep us happy the the creators
happy let me give everybody happy and so
but if you don't understand your story
world
you won't understand that story
potential so so in story worlds are a
really important tool to be able to
maximize the stored potential in your IP
so you just have to understand first off
what a story world is like what it is at
all then how do we how do we create it
so so a couple a couple easy ways that
that some easy tips that people can
start thinking about as they create
story world is they need to be thinking
first about their theme about what they
want to say and about what their
perspective is it goes back to that
passion like what what's the what what
what's the commentary that they're
trying to put into any individual story
and then once you understand that then
the starting point for a great story
world is a place
that needs your soapbox or your theme so
for example if you if you if your theme
was all about income inequality about
how the evils of income inequality there
and you want to show people that and and
and tell people that equality of income
is actually like the ideal for society
let's see that's what you want to say
the starting place or the starting point
for your story world is a place that
needs that message which means that's a
place where income inequality is gonna
be a tremendous problem that's your
starting point
it isn't just like oh I'll just set it
in Philadelphia or I'll set it in a
fantasy world with wizards that's not
the starting point the starting point is
what am I trying to say with my movie
what am I trying to say with my book
where I want trying to say with my video
game and what's a world that needs to
hear that message and so if you if under
the income inequality example maybe your
story world is a sci-fi story world like
at Liam where the rich folks live in the
sky and the poor folks live you know on
the ground or maybe it's a real world
story world like India where
billionaires and slum Dogz live like two
blocks apart right so it can it can be
or anywhere on that spectrum right
Angeles or Los Angeles exactly and so
but that's the starting point is what's
the world that needs my what's a world
that needs my soapbox or needs my theme
one of my favorite story world's just in
the past couple years is show called
godless that was on Steven Soderbergh
produced it for now Netflix great
high-concept which was which was a town
with us Old West town where all the men
and the town died in a mining accident
and so the only people that are left in
the town are the women and the women
sort of run the you know run run the
town protect the town do everything in
the town and so so you if you listen to
the creator's talk the thing that they
wanted to say with the show it's a great
show the thing they wanted to say is
that women can be every bit as strong as
men women can do just as cool awesome
interesting cool things as men that's
what they wanted to show they want to
give a vehicle for this message and
a world that need that that needs to
hear that could be a medieval world
could be a sci-fi world but they
children chose the Old West so the Old
West you know is all about like the
man's man on the horse and the women and
the dress that weighs the raise that the
kids at home and it was very patriarchal
in the way society was set up and
everybody looked through the men to do
the to do the cool awesome things and no
one looked at the women to do those
things and so the starting place for
that story world is a world that needs
that message which is the Old West
right and so and so that basically once
you understand your theme that kind of
puts guardrails on your the ideation
process of your story world to where now
you just know you need a world that need
your theme which will necessarily
eliminate certain ideas right so you
don't if it's in an income inequality
you don't want to have your story world
be a place where income and quality
isn't a problem it'll eliminate those
those story world options and then limit
you to the ones that do but ultimately
if you do that the benefit of this is
that it takes your soap box and your
theme and it bakes it into the cake of
the story world itself so that every
story that you ever explore within that
story world will naturally intrinsically
communicate your message it will be in
the DNA like woven into the DNA of the
story run itself
we never no matter where we go in
Jurassic Park they never to have to tell
us that it's a bad idea to have made
dinosaurs we just know it and we know it
because the the the the soap box of
Jurassic Park which I think is don't
play God because when we try to play God
we screw it up that is built into the
idea itself it's built into the story
board itself and it's always there right
which is which is which is really
interesting and so so the starting point
but with with with story world it's what
do you want to say what's your
perspective what's your commentary and
then how do we create a world that needs
that then what you need to do is you
need to layer in I think a high concept
which is which is just a commercially
interesting idea something that is
immediately interesting
and that can grab people's attention and
I think a lot of people focus on high
concept when it comes to story and not
and not out people don't focus on how to
create a high concept for the world
itself because the world itself needs to
be interesting and commercial and it
needs to grab people's attention just as
much as the characters and the story so
so a town that a town where all the men
died and completely run by women it's a
great high concept right so so the
interest isn't on a specific character
or a specific storyline the interest is
on the town itself in what lost the the
high concept as a as an island that
travels through time and all this weird
stuff happens we can take any of those
individual characters out of that island
that Island is still interesting because
I Island has a high concept the Skoll
Island with the king in the King Kong
franchise there's something about Skull
Island
that creates giant animals so I can take
King Kong out of Scotland and they're
still interesting things there there's
the high concept that's attached to the
world and so and so figuring out irony
of what what's something that surprises
you about this world something that is
is interesting so I think Zootopia is a
great example and made it sense of where
this is a world where where animals live
as civilized humans right and there's a
that's irony and that and the that's
irony attached to the world itself then
they were able to take an ironic world
and create an ironic story or a high
concept story inside the high concept
world where now they had a little tiny
bunny the one to be a police officer and
all the other police officers were like
the giant rhinos and everything so they
had a high concept character high cost
plot but the world itself was
independently high-concept right and
that's what makes the world interesting
and that's what creates the story
potential over time so so you have to
think about so a lot of us a lot of
filmmakers will naturally understand a
logline
what's a log line for your story and
that's just a really one sentence way to
be able to encapsulate
your plot and in a way that's
interesting it makes people want to read
your script I'm very bullish on creating
a log line for your story world in
addition to your individual stories and
so a log line a story world log line
goes something like this a story world
is a place where ironic things happen
that's a template I always use for a
story world and if you can if you could
just use that template and say the story
world is a place where ironic things
happen then you will always have
something interesting so for example uh
Neverland is the story of rope Neverland
is a faraway Fantasyland where people
don't age and live as kids forever right
so the story world is a place
what kind of is is what kind of places
is this city is it a country is it a
galaxy no it's a far away fantasy land
and where's the irony what's the
surprising part of it what's the
interesting part of it it's a place
where you don't age and remain as a kid
forever right so if you go if you go
through your story world and you say can
I make a story about logline out of it
that's independently interesting and by
adding in irony and a high concept to
the world itself now you have some
commercial 'ti and some interest and
something that is that that by itself
can grab people's attention
what about Gilead in The Handmaid's Tale
or sauropod I don't know if you watched
your sharp objects yeah what would about
that story world can you do so so
obviously with with that with with a
hand Hamming scale
I think the irony is the high concept of
that of that world one that's it that's
when we're talking about soapbox and put
your message and how to create a story
world that needs that message when it
talks about the reproductive what rights
of women I think that's very clearly the
commentary of the patriarchy controlling
the reproductive rights rights of women
that's a world that needs to hear that
message obviously and then then they
layer in the high concept which is you
know not not every woman can give birth
and there's some women that can't give
birth that are not controlled and forced
to give birth but it's like these four
surrogates that's the big commercial
idea but it's the big commercial idea
rooted in an important message right
which it which is kind of interesting
how those flow together which
gets you to the point of where your
story world is now not just cool the
coolness comes through the high-concept
but it's also important and the
importance comes through the soap box
they work together for the whole thing
so I think The Handmaid's Tale is a
tremendous story world tremendously
interesting story world outside of any
individual character outside of any
individual story someone can tell me the
concept of the story world itself and
I'm in that's interesting that's cool
and now I want to go check it out I can
see that where the story potential is
excetera et cetera
I think with with windgap and sharp
objects I think windgap is a small win a
small Midwest town where everybody has a
secret nothing is as it seems
I mean just the way they built that
world was really interesting even with
like the teenagers that rollerskate
around town that one little addition
they're not writing back to the roller
skating which added this really
interesting element to it right and so
just the way they crafted that world it
wasn't just like any other normal small
town it was a small town with a dark
underbelly that was very difficult for
anybody to to tap into it had this like
weird veneer but it was it was just a
really interesting world I think with
with stranger things right Hawkins is a
small Indiana town that is a portal to
an other Mir Dark Mirror dimension right
one sentence you understand the high
concept the commercial 'ti of that world
right I can take Mike and the gang in
the dimming organ and everybody out of
out of stranger things and Hawkins is
still interesting because the high
concept is attached to the world itself
the problem is a lot of people design
films and TV and novels and things like
that with a high concept attached to the
character which means if you pull the
character out now the place is no longer
interesting which means you've tied your
IP to that specific character which
means you're going to limit your story
potential in your story options across
platform because the high concepts with
him The Fresh Prince of bel-air
for example Fresh Prince of bel-air
right the height the high concept there
is the fish-out-of-water concept of you
know a West Philly street hustler
whose removed from West Philly and now
lives in bel-air right that's the high
concept but if I take will out of The
Fresh Prince bel-air is no longer
interesting it's interesting because
he's there because the high concept
lives with him right
same thing with Beverly Hills Cop right
it means the same thing and Beverly
Hillbillies the whole thing right
someone's take a shared story world the
people that aren't supposed to be there
that are there right but if you if you
take out those characters now we can't
follow one of my favorite story rules is
the leftovers it's a HBO show three
seasons tremendous story world where two
percent of the world's population
disappears instantly and nobody knows
where they went and the hot so you can
follow with with that with that high
concept you can follow any character in
that world and the world is still
interesting because this is this is a
world where people can just disappear
and you don't know why right so we buy
in and we're interested because of the
world that's where the interest comes
and then if you can tell me I if you can
tell me a commercial story inside a
commercial world all of a sudden now
you're hitting on all levels right
because ultimately you have to have a
great story inside a high concept world
else your product isn't good but one of
the if you remember the movie Jupiter
ascending with Channing Tatum milah
Kunis was the the Wachowskis that you
know after their masterpiece of The
Matrix they went and created ascending
which I thought it was a tremendous
story world but a really really bad
story and so when you have a great world
and a bad story everything falls apart
because your product just simply isn't
good and the same with Tomorrowland with
George Clooney tomorrow man it's awesome
but the movie was bad so so that sort of
killed the whole thing but if you can
tell a great story inside a great world
this is when you have IP potential
forever
because your product is great and the
story world is independently interesting
which is gonna create more more
opportunities for you moving forward
what about the original Blade Runner
I think the whole world of Blade Runner
is really interesting I think the world
itself I think is high concept so you
know with the replica
and you know and and you know our people
sort of these robots aren't they robots
or like you know like that whole the
world is interesting and especially even
this in the in the Scimitar fee the the
color especially the new film blood
rather 2049 like you just see like the
way they colorize it and and and insert
this like steampunk dystopian future the
world I think like without what you take
Karason for it out still cool like it's
just still really interesting but dune
is another great one like you take like
like that's a great story world and so
so so for fans like you can take the
Starks the Starks at a game of Thrones I
think humans are still interesting right
like the the high concept is with with
the place
now I think you can even take you can
take wall-e out of wall-e and the world
is still interesting right and so so
this is just an interesting tactic to
judge does the world have viability in
and of itself right so you want to have
a soapbox to sort of sort of spurs the
initial creation then you want to layer
in the high concept which builds the
interest of mortal engines which Peter
the new Peter Jackson movie that's
coming out based on the books I think
it's a really interesting high concept
where where this is a dystopian future
where cities roll around on wheels like
tank wheels so London rolls around and
it like cities move and I saw the teaser
I've never read the books I saw the
teaser and I said huh that's weird I
don't know why cities roll around on
wheels in this weird dystopian future
but they do and now I'm interested
because I buy into the story world
itself one thing I think is really
interesting that can help filmmakers is
really pay attention to what's going on
in videogames so the video game industry
has made more money last year than
movies television and music combined
made 148 billion dollars worldwide
tremendous so two video games are doing
something that nobody else is doing any
of any other industry and if you pay
attention to how the video games are
promoting
and getting people interested in their
IP you will see that video games the the
thing they push most or story world's
they will get you interested in the
story world itself before anything else
before they sell you on mechanics before
they sell you on style before they sell
you wants individual story they the high
concept is always going to be attached
to the story world itself whether it's
fallout whether its death stranding
whether it's fortnight where it's a
battle is it's a crazy place for where
people drop out of a school bus into
this like ever-shrinking world that you
can build forts there's like whatever it
is the way they sell and the way they
get interest is because they're pushing
for forward story worlds that are
independently interesting beyond any one
character or one story and so I think
filmmakers can look at that now I don't
think you have to have a big budget to
have a good high concept story world
like again a high concept story world
isn't doesn't have to be Star Wars it
doesn't have to be Harry Potter like a
great high concept story world can exist
in a hundred thousand dollar feature
that like it doesn't change the way you
create an idea one of my favorite
stories about that is the purge purge is
a great high concept story world where
the per the purchase is dystopian
America where all crime is legal for
1224 hours whatever it is and that's a
story world logline it's easily
understandable has irony in the line
itself
it gets interest into the world but when
you go watch the original purge movie
it's all set in a house they don't leave
the house and that's all you know you
talk to filmmakers and and and they'll
understand any movie that never leaves
the house mm-hmm excuse me it's because
a budget it's a cost-saving mechanism to
only have one location so they had a
very small budget and they and so they
couldn't go explore this tremendous
world that they that they they had
created right so what I loved about that
is is really what they didn't do what
they didn't do is say you know what we
have this really cool idea for a world
but we only have a very
small budget to make a movie so let's
just not let's just set aside our high
concept world and just make a movie
about bad guys try to kill people inside
of a house and we'll save our cool story
world concept for for later when we have
a big budget what they did they said no
no will will create the world and and
then we'll execute inside a house
because that's all the budget we have
and then if that's successful then guess
what they did and the purge too they
went outside the house and being in
exploring the world so what happens is
even if you have a really high concept
story world idea but a small budget you
can execute in that small budget but
then when you go to create the second
story and the third story you now have a
growth plan and room to now grow
organically inside that world because if
they were to come out with the second
movie and said oh yeah by the way you
can kill people for one day and they
added the high-concept the second time
around
it would have been inauthentic and so
I'm very very much an advocate for
designing designing a 40,000 square foot
blueprint for a house and this large
story world that has independent
interest even if you can only build one
room because when you build the first
room what happens is if if it works and
everything goes well you can go start to
build the second room and the third room
and now you have a growth plan for your
plumbing connects and your electrical
connects and everything like works well
as you grow out and then maybe you get
to a bigger room and a bigger room and a
bigger room where you can explore more
things so and if it doesn't work all
you've done is burnt one creative idea
and you should have a hundred more and
so so I think a great story world is
independent of budget but at the same
time communicate to the audience that
this is interesting beyond just one
story and if an audience recognizes that
guess who also recognizes that it's a
buyer
it's an investor right so so so savvy
buyers and savvy investors can they look
at certain projects now and they say
that's a great world because listen if
you sell something to the studio as an
independent writer you sell something to
studio you're going to
rewritten anyway they're gonna put
somebody on it that that is sort of a
you know a tried-and-true studio writer
it's gonna rewrite your stuff anyway
right so so our studio if they identify
a script that has a great story world
where they know they can get 10 or 12 or
a hundred stories over the next 10 years
across seven different platforms the
investment they make into that script
that has that world is is a better
investment than the one off script
that's going to be one really good movie
but doesn't give a consideration to any
store to a story world aspect to it
right so so the studio is the network's
and the investors they're looking for
market potential and story potential but
your story potential is directly linked
to the revenue potential which is also
directly linked to the story world
itself and so and so you actually you
actually position yourself for a for a
better chance of acquisition when you
have a story world that shows off the
revenue potential and the story
potential across platform even listen
even if you don't come up with all the
other stuff even if you don't say this
is the video game and this is the fit
this is the the Instagram thing if you
just have a tremendous world and sell
the world with the story savvy buyers
will recognize that potential for you
sometimes they think well this guy
doesn't even know what he has right and
and and so what we see now in the
industry it's really interesting to past
two years what's been going on is that
studios have been acquiring story worlds
without stories like you think you I
just have to have the independents like
the feature film script of the whole
thing not necessarily because there's a
lot of short films that have been
created that that don't have feature
concept that don't even have stories all
they do is have a story world concept
that within a week have created calls
bidding wars between the studios the
studio's want the world they they have
they have overall deals with with
writers and directors and producers
already that they can drop in that world
to write any script or develop whatever
what they need is the IP and so
tremendous stories is is there's an
artist the Scandinavian artist named
stuck
Simon Stalin hog and he creates he's a
painter and he creates these paintings
that are tremendous they all they all
have like dystopian sci-fi story world
elements Amazon approaches approaches
him and says we love this story world
you're creating in your painting we want
to make a TV show set in this world
he sold us he sold a TV show to Amazon
without ever writing a pilot script
without even wanting to write because he
just created a tremendous world that
Amazon said that has potential and we
want to play in that sandbox right so
making sure you have a commercial idea
that is attached to the world itself
that is that's a tremendous thing also
thinking beyond individual characters
understanding character groups and and
so I think that that is a smart tactical
way to develop story world's you're not
thinking about Luke Skywalker you think
about Jedi you're not thinking about
Frodo you're thinking about the hobbits
right you don't think about Iron Man
you're think about superheroes and them
because the more characters you have
more character groups you have you
increased or you increase three
potential and make your world a better
populated place with more interesting
people and I think adding in what I call
special sauce to your story world is
really important because a lot of
especially now is it very difficult to
come up with the story world idea that
hasn't been done it's completely unique
and so what I encourage a lot of a lot
of people to do is as they develop their
individual story worlds if they find
that their story world is similar to
other people's story worlds that's okay
what they need to do is just go in and
add three or four new rules within the
world a special sauce that
differentiates them from the convention
for example vampire story worlds have
been done forever Stephenie Meyer said
I'm still gonna do vampires even though
vampire story worlds have been done
forever but I'm gonna change two or
three rules within my vampire story
world I'm going instead of them being
soulless emotionless beasts my vampires
are going to be super emo love
instead of them melting in the sunlight
they're gonna Sparkle right I like that
she just she changed like two or three
rules all of a sudden this story world
in Twilight feels fresh and new
right like wizard stuff have been it has
been done forever but JK Rowling made
these children wizards and and gave it a
little fresh twist that just made that
story world feel fresh and new and so so
find a way just to - if you're doing
zombies or if you're doing you know
something in space you're doing
something in like sword and sandal
fantasy figure out the one or two or
three rules that you can change within
that world that just makes it feel
different than Star Trek or Game of
Thrones or you know whatever else and
and if you add that special sauce the
little tweak to a world that has a
commercially interesting idea that's
rooted in the thematic then all of a
sudden you are light years ahead of any
creator that just is trying to write
like the one individual script you you
are now on the way to creating a really
robust and interesting story world
you